we're at a critical juncture in terms of
seizing the opportunity to have a
thriving life sciences sector in the
future and to make sure that we have a
world-class patient outcomes in the NHS
but what specifically does extra money
need to be spent on what we see in terms
of a thriving life sciences sector is is
important that the NHS is world-class
and that means two things to us making
sure that we have the right investment
there and actually we don't invest even
today at average of the g7 at the levels
other countries do so that's what we're
calling for because that investment is
important to make sure we stay
competitive when we have a world-class
NHS that's good for patients it's also
good for the life sciences sector and we
also want to see medicines access for
patients at a level comparable to other
countries so that's what we're calling
for today so some conservative MPs Jacob
Riis MOG for example have accused your
special pleading how do you respond to
that I think what we're about in the
manifesto is saying we want to seize the
opportunity for both for the industry of
life sciences to stay well leading but
also to make sure that NHS patients
benefit from that and a to go hand in
hand in a thriving life sciences sector
so we see it important to have the
dialogue now to make sure that a new
government sets the right policy
framework to seize those opportunities
but the magnitude of spending increase
that you're talking about twenty point
eight billion pounds that's equivalent
to four pence on the basic rate of
income tax I mean how would you pay for
this increase so what we're calling for
is for the NHS to be world-class to have
a level of investment that we think
matches the ambition to be world leading
in life sciences what that means is to
look at what would be average for the
top g7 countries so just to move us to
average is the ask for the manifesto to
say this is what we think it would take
to be world class and world leading
so to move to that average level that's
a discussion that we would need to have
with the government what we're saying is
that to seize this opportunity we
believe to secure this opportunity both
for patients and for the life sciences
sector we need that investment does
higher spending on the NHS guarantee the
kind of outcomes that you're looking for
humming Gordon Brown increase the NHS
budget year after year after year and it
didn't really do a lot for NHS
productivity I think the level of
investment in the NHS needs to be at a
good level so that's why we're calling
for average of the g7 to secure the
right patient outcomes but absolutely
the focus on NHS patients benefitting
and the focus on patient outcomes to
make sure that investment is put in the
right places is critical and that's why
we see the two things going hand-in-hand
what will be the industry response if
you don't get what you're looking for
are we talking about disinvestment in
the UK what we're looking at here is to
say we think this is a critical point
critical juncture as we come through the
break suits discussions as we're working
closely and collaboratively with the
government on industrial strategy right
right now is the time to say what policy
interventions do we think we need to
secure the opportunity for the future
and that's what we're really focused on
but is that going to mean less
investment by the industry in the UK
life sciences sector it is important
that the next government makes the
policy decisions that makes the UK
attractive for investment for all types
of companies that's what we're saying in
the manifesto